foreign
what's up guys George Campbell here
co-host of the Ramsey Show and we are
back with another loaded episode of the
best of the Ramsey Show and today we're
talking about some stuff that might
intimidate you investing and retirement
and we're also going to answer your
biggest questions on everything from the
stock market to mutual funds plus how to
save for your dream retirement check
this out Beverly's with us Beverly's in
Boise Idaho hi Beverly how are you
hi Dave
hi hi Ken thank you for taking my call
sure what's up I have a very simple
question for you
how much cash is too much cash to keep
at home
and where would you put it where should
you put it since the banks are only
giving you one percent
[Music]
so you're a cash under the mattress
woman are you
uh-huh
maybe it's some coffee cans buried in
the backyard
[Laughter]
so how much cash do you want to keep at
home
well you always say 10
pounds to The Car Store and put seventy
thousand dollars of cash on their debt
so you cannot go down to the what store
the automobile Store and put seventy
thousand dollars cash did you say 70
yeah you're buying a nice car
buy a new car to buy a new car you're
buying a nice truck all right well I I
don't do that when I'm buying a seventy
thousand dollar item I wire it
okay I don't carry cash in now if I'm
negotiating with an individual for a
used item I might use the power of cash
like we have taught and wave it under
their nose and see if I can get a better
deal I've done that I'm not above doing
that but I don't I um
I don't I don't think I'm going to
recommend Beverly walks down with a
suitcase full of money like a drug
dealer to a seventy thousand dollar car
purchase I'm just going to let you wire
that money in
so you would put the money in the bank
and wire it and get one percent well
you're not getting anything in the
bottom of your mattress
that's true yeah so it's it's you know I
know that it's not the one percent it's
I don't want you to get robbed I don't
want somebody knocking the head and take
70 grand out of your house
I don't have 70 grand in my house
so that's just when you say you pay cash
for stuff you keep your money in a bank
or a credit union or something and then
you hire it yeah and I wire it and
meaning I don't go into debt is what I
mean when I pay cash now I have a pocket
full of cash right now I I carry a uh
you know a money clip in my front pocket
that's usually got a thousand bucks in
it but that just because I like how I'm
a redneck I like having some money in my
pocket right you know but that's just
walking around money and if I want to
buy something or you know most of what
that wallet goes for is tips
for you know when I park a car or when
I'm uh finish up playing a game of golf
and a guy cleans my clubs you know that
kind of stuff or when I come over and
mow your lawn yeah when the kid comes
over and washes dishes for us we give
him a little tip and by the way I want
to point out don't don't come to some
live event and try to take money off of
Dave because he's also got something
else in his in his backpack
I can't point that out that could be a
bad scenario
I'm not going to get robbed it's okay
nobody wants to rob me but the uh I'm
not really muggable I'm just huggable
but the uh uh uh yeah the uh but anyway
the uh uh yeah I don't walk around with
a bunch of cash in that regard by when I
say cash is King at the beginning of the
show it doesn't mean that Jesus isn't
King it means the the cat that cash has
power and paying for things rather than
going into debt to get them is power and
so
um you know I I know a few people that
keep five or ten thousand dollars cash
in a little safe in their house just in
case they you know wanted to grab a hold
of a little money for some reason or
another on a short notice and the ATM
was jammed up or something then that's
okay but I you know I I don't believe in
keeping 50 100 200 000
you're starting to get into the land of
Preppers and stuff like that then and
I'm I'm not I'm not that guy
Steve is with us Steve's in New York
City hi Steve how are you
hey Dave and John thanks for taking my
call appreciate it sure what's up
uh well recently retired about a year
now 53 years old I have my work
retirement but uh my mom has passed away
uh 18 months ago we sold her house and I
inherited uh 150 000 that way uh now
it's up to me to uh to invest it through
mutual funds and not super duper
comfortable with it and I have some
ideas but uh I don't I don't know
between regular mutual funds tax
deferred mutual funds uh do I go all in
with the 150 or do I piecemeal it
and do you have any debt
um currently just my uh one son's
college she's a senior how much do you
owe on that
uh we probably owe another 35
000 for him okay we need to set that
aside right
uh yeah we have that and we have some
savings okay and so there's no debt
associated with the college you just
have an obligation
correct okay all right do you have a
home mortgage
uh not any longer nope good for you good
for you okay couple of things on
investing
um let's start at the top number one you
don't invest in things that you don't
understand
you never invest in things because some
goob on the radio like me said do it or
some goob on the internet that's even
worse said do it okay so you understand
it
and the Bible says in the multitude of
counsel there is safety and what that
means is you get some experts around you
to give you advice
and the advice is not that you follow
the expert the advice is so that you
understand something you didn't
understand before so your financial
people need to have the heart of a
teacher
so that when you sit down with your
financial person and you get up and
leave you need to know something you
didn't know before you sit down every
time
every time I spent an hour and a half in
my office yesterday with our chief
digital officer and three of our top uh
senior uh Tech Guys and they were trying
to teach me
oh geez that's why you're in such a
great mood today about about digital
about our digital platform and I don't I
do not have to be a digital expert to be
the CEO of this digital company but I do
have to grasp the vernacular and I do
have to grasp enough of it to help them
to make wise decisions under their help
so the multitude of council these
experts are in my office teaching me
about my company yesterday in this case
they're teaching you about your money
that you inherited from your the passing
of your parent right and so you're going
to gather that up you do not have to
have an MBA in finance in order to make
easy financial decisions basic investing
decisions now so rule number one is you
don't want to do it unless you
understand it rule number two is you put
somebody in your life that has the heart
of a teacher you can click smartvestor
Pro daveramsey.com or smart investor and
find the person in your area we
recommend they don't work for us they
pay us an endorsement fee and they have
to agree to approach you're investing
the way that we teach and with the heart
of a teacher I personally invest Steve
inside my retirement accounts in four
types of Mutual Funds growth growth and
income aggressive growth and
international outside of retirement
accounts those funds all create taxes
each year as they grow that's a problem
there's two ways to avoid that with your
hundred and fifty thousand my preference
is and the one that I personally do is I
invest in Mutual Funds growth stock
mutual funds that have what's called a
low turnover ratio now you ready for the
teaching part
okay here we go if you buy a rental
house for two hundred thousand dollars
and it goes up in value to three hundred
thousand dollars and you still own it
you do not owe taxes on that one hundred
thousand in growth because you've not
sold the house agreed
correct
so you've got capital gains growth
but you don't have any taxes because
you've not sold it
stock is the same way if a share of
stock goes from fifty dollars to seventy
dollars you don't pay taxes on that
twenty dollar gain until you sell it
same is true inside a mutual fund the
turnover ratio is when they sell the
stock inside the mutual fund if it has a
90 turnover ratio that means almost all
the stocks get sold every year and so
all those gains are going to be taxable
every year
if they have a five percent right if
they have a five percent turnover ratio
which is a low turnover ratio that means
you're not going to pay taxes on the
increase in value
until you sell the mutual fund because
they aren't selling the stocks inside
the mutual funds hardly at all
much like that rental house or that
share of stock did that make sense it
definitely did so uh that low turnover
what number am I looking at is it you
want an under 10 turnover ratio
under 10 okay because anything that
turns over the gain is they're going to
send you a tax bill on the gain every
year every every year yes okay so you
want it to not turn over hardly at all
so that it only grows without taxes
until you sell it now if you hold it a
year when you sell it you're going to be
taxed at capital gains rate 15 percent
rather than
the ordinary income right thirty percent
forty percent
Cynthia is with us Cynthia is in Des
Moines Iowa hi Cynthia how are you
hi Dave doing great thanks for taking my
call sure
um I just have a quick question so I am
on I am hoping to get on to baby step
four really soon so my question is
around baby step four
um I'm wanting to contribute about 15 to
my 401k great hoping like this next
paycheck or possibly in February
um but I'm noticing that the market is
well it's in the toilet so
should I really contribute at this time
or should I skip it and move on to like
something else or when I was a little
kid my my mama would take us to a store
called Kmart
yeah and Kmart would in the middle of
the day run these little sails they
called them Blue Light Special Blue
Light Special they would turn on a blue
light over the top of the whatever area
and uh you could go there and get you a
coffee pot on sale or whatever that's
what you that's what we're having right
now darling this is called a Blue Light
Special you need to buy it it's on sale
buy while it's on sale
okay
so you know why
how old are you
uh I'm 40 ish okay 40-ish
Own It own it I'm 61. I'm proud of it so
there you go but the uh uh yeah so
here's the thing uh
in 20 years
where do you think an average
of companies that sound like this
Apple Coca-Cola McDonald's
Boeing Microsoft
Home Depot
on average as a group now there'll be
someone or two that fail but on average
as a group an aggregate of that group 20
years from now are they going to be
worth more or less
well not only ideally there would be the
that's what has always happened in
history 100 of the time so far in the
American stock market's history now
obviously the world can fall apart and
we can just blow this whole thing up
called America but if anything stays
similar to what it is
20 years from today it's going to be up
and you will be glad that you bought in
the cold winter of 2022 when the market
was freezing to death and down because
of whatever was going on out there I
haven't even seen something going on how
far down is it I've even looked I
dropped 500 points in one day the other
day but it's just it's back and forth
let me see out of thirty thousand five
hundred points used to be a lot it's not
anymore but yeah yeah it's uh Ukraine
and uh and Biden mumbling and they can't
nobody you know nobody's getting uh idea
that he's going to do anything and so
the Market's just unstable geopolitical
crap always destabilizes the market it
always has I mean this little thing
happens on this side of the world and
boom all of a sudden because people just
have this little black cloud following
around on Wall Street just waiting for
the next bad thing waiting on the next
bad thing and then they're psychological
as it can be but uh um Bitcoins in half
oh God who knew I knew that was going to
happen and so anybody with investing
wisdom of more than eight to ten years
yeah yeah that's true but um yeah fairly
fairly easy predictor but fairly you
know easy predictor and this is just a
you know uh it is a geopolitical driven
it's not economic driven and it's not
profits the profits of the companies
involved have not changed so are they
suddenly worth less right no they're so
worth what they were worth it's just
they're scared they might be down in the
future because of war with Russia or
China or destabilization of the
political environment all that kind of
crap
so do I think all that's going to happen
nope
I think there's going to be problems and
there's going to be times when there's
not problems and the Market's going to
go up the Market's going to go down and
I only people get hurt on a roller
coaster are those that jump off in the
middle of the right
Beau in Dallas Texas hey Bo welcome to
the show
I appreciate it thanks for having me on
absolutely how can we help
so I'm 23 I've been working a job for
about 10 months out of college make good
money make about 78 000 a year in a
couple months I should be getting a
raise anywhere from 90 to 100. I've
always been pretty uh pretty good save
my money for about past five years I've
got about 20 000 in a Fidelity account
fifteen thousand in Bitcoin which I know
you guys are gonna you know give me the
land face about maybe not but and then
about 5 000 in a company 401K with a
match but my question is I only have
about three thousand dollars in my
checking account and then the
inflationary environment we're in you
know I'm losing my purchasing power
every day just keeping the money in my
checking account and you know I'm 23
single don't really think I need to save
up for a house in this crazy housing
market should I be concerned about
having the slow amount of cash in my
checking account you know if an
emergency comes up I could just you know
sell somebody stock or some like Bitcoin
so that's kind of my question should I
you know uh keep my cash balance low and
keep the aggressive investing up or
maybe you know try and beef up that
checking account yeah I mean it's a
great question
um you know I always answer these
questions that if I woke up in your
shoes and for me having liquid cash just
to get where there's no strings attached
there's no Hoops I have to jump through
hurdles I have to get over that I can
just literally get it right now now if I
needed it gives me a sense of peace and
if there's something that happens that
you have to have cash having something
just available that's not tied up in
Investments or even Bitcoin I really do
recommend so that's kind of our three to
six months worth of expenses uh when we
talk about baby step three do you have
any debt at all are you completely debt
free no I'm debt free I was lucky enough
I didn't have to pay for college
so yeah I'm debt free very cool you're
doing an incredible job Bo I mean the
questions you're asking at 23 is it's
impressive so if I were you yeah I would
I would have some money and you can even
start saving for it now if you want
um you know and just saying hey I'm on
baby step three and then start saving
for that fully funded emergency funds
um you could do that because if you if
you love this other stuff that you have
your money in but I would probably just
cash out
um one of those Investments probably the
Bitcoin I know you're not shocked that I
want to say it's not doing great anyways
bro let's be honest
yeah thank you but here's what I'm
thinking why can't you do both why not
have a fully funded emergency fund and
be investing so I think right now your
next goal should be to beef up your
savings uh leave that money in checking
and create a three to six months
expenses savings account and then you
can begin investing 15 beyond that start
saving up for a house is that your next
goal
yeah I think eventually that's the route
I want to go to my like my one thing
with that is I know you know investing
at a young age is so much more important
than investing later on and with you
know the market taking such a big hit
right now I think you know it's just
such a great opportunity to keep you
know in like uh really aggressively
investing at this age yeah and it is so
and I even love the framework that you
have when it comes to the market because
a lot of people are panicked and freaked
out and they don't want to put money in
when you're in a position that you're in
with no debts and you have you know soon
an emergency fund that's where the
perfect time to be investing
aggressively so yeah you're exactly on
the right track Bo I don't think that
you're gonna go wrong anywhere here I
would I would though have some money
liquid just in case something happens
you're able to get to it quickly to your
question about you were saying that the
liquid cash scares you because it's not
beating inflation but the purpose of the
emergency fund is not to be an
investment it's insurance and so
Insurance protects what you're trying to
build and so I'm totally okay with your
emergency fund not being invested and
just sitting in a boring savings account
making you one percent I'm totally good
with that because when an emergency hits
I don't want you dipping into your
investment accounts to cover that I want
you to cover that with your emergency
fund that's what it's there for so I
like keeping things neat and tidy and
separate so that when no one gets
confused here and uh to your question of
investing aggressively you're going to
be a multi-millionaire just based on the
numbers you told me if you don't
lifestyle creep into your life as you
get this raise you keep living on lesson
you make you invest I also know there's
other goals it's not all about investing
you have to live your life you've got to
go on vacations you're going to want to
upgrade the car you're going to want to
buy a house so balance it a little bit I
I can tell with young investors Rachel
which I love I know they can they tend
to get real tunnel vision when it comes
to investing that's all they think about
well that's a good point because and
it's easy to because you see the math
and like what he said he's like I know
investing early on is so much better
because you see compound interest so you
see the math you see the dollar signs in
your eyes you're like heck why would I
do anything else except for put money in
because of what it could do with
compound interest but you don't factor
in life into the equation and who knows
Bo you can meet a girl tomorrow and you
kind of could have fall in love and
you're going to want an engagement ring
you know what I'm saying like anything
can happen in life and having money
there uh is huge and having it as part
of your life strategy knowing that yes
while investing is exciting and the
earlier start the better off you're
going to be all of that but there's also
life and with the numbers you shared Bo
I'm seeing a lot of what I assume is
single stocks in the Fidelity account
potentially and Bitcoin and a little bit
in the 401K I would flip-flop that and
lean into the 401K invest in good growth
stock mutual funds and then if you want
to play with some crypto or single
stocks on the side that's fine but I
don't want it to be a large portion of
your net worth because they are way more
volatile than your mutual funds yeah
when your whole retirement
uh if if all of your retirement is in
Bitcoin which I know Bose isn't but
that's that's not a great plan not a
great plan agreed Mary is with us Mary
is in Los Angeles hi Mary welcome to the
Ramsay show
thank you for taking my call I
appreciate your time sure
we're a little
um
concerned about our situation my husband
and I are retired we're 65. we received
pension and social security
uh we have a mortgage of is probably
400 and maybe 50 60 000 on our home
um we have an income after taxes of
about
8
370 per month we do pay a lot out for
our bills
we have
um
one major bill that's 28 000. we have a
balance of about 10 000 on a car
and the and that's all I did you don't
have any nest egg
we have a fifty five thousand dollars in
the bank and about 41 000 and 457
between the two of us
and write a check today and pay off your
car
but we don't want to keep
her then sell that car today
okay you need to get rid of the debt
okay okay that's first thing that's a
quick one easy one quick win all right
and so
um
what's your house payment
2400.
okay with taxes and everything okay
a little high but not a deal breaker uh
out of 8 300 you can pay 2400 out of
83.70 and that leaves you six thousand
dollars a month to live on you are in
Los Angeles so you have a high cost of
living but you you know once we wrote
that check we've got housing covered
which is your big dog
uh if you've got no other debts because
we just started paying them off you have
six thousand dollars a month to live on
you can't live on that with a budget I
think you can even in LA but I have the
twenty eight thousand dollar bill what's
that on
uh we Consolidated a lot of bills and we
did one where zero percent interest on
the credit card okay until next late
next year okay so you need to pay that
off too
okay so if you if you sell the truck the
car what are you gonna be driving
we have one other vehicle okay
so if you sell the car and got rid of
that debt and you wrote a check and paid
that off it gets rid of a bunch of your
cash but you got all this stuff hanging
over your head I'm feeling the stress in
your voice from these debts
yes and I want to set you free from
those debts and then you can start to
live on a budget and you can actually
save money in this situation
of course the other option is you can
add income to the equation if you guys
chose to have an encore career you're
just 65 I'm 61 and I feel fine you're
going to be all right
John's in Kansas City hey John welcome
to the Ramsey Show
thank you sir I appreciate you taking
the call sure
my wife and I Pastor a small church and
we've been FPU coordinators and I've
trained other people in that thank you
matter of fact I'm not saying it's for
accolades but I uh every time we marry
someone we give them a copy of The Total
Money Makeover and wow write a note in
there to follow the biblical principles
that are in this book and many of them
have gotten debt free
my issue today is I'm 66 I don't have
much money uh saved for retirement we
don't make a lot of money like I said we
Pastor a small Church there's been times
we've had to skip taking a paycheck that
kind of thing my wife does work outside
the home we're both receiving Social
Security now
so that supplements our income but
um I don't have a lot of money saved or
just concerned about you know we're
going to have enough money to live on
important false and uh uh we we're debt
free except for our house we don't owe a
lot of money on that
oh 85 000 on the house and it's worth
600 and how much in this tank have you
got
uh about 30 35
000.
yes okay
all right and what's your household
income these days
uh we're about seventy thousand dollars
uh including everything okay
um and are both of you planning to stay
in the same uh work situation for the
next few years
yes yeah I I plan to stay here you know
it's uh it's not a career choice with me
it's actually a calling and I appreciate
that otherwise I might might have had
something that had a better look for
something and had a better pay package
but it's really it's really not about
that it's about ministering to people
absolutely and this is just where I'm at
in a great heart and so uh you know what
I would tell you is I got two goals for
you in five years
perfect I'm ready for you get the house
paid off and put a hundred thousand
dollars for mutual funds
okay still not going to be still not
going to be enough
but you'll be 71 and you'd have a
hundred and
uh
170 approaching two hundred thousand
dollars in there with the growth of the
35 efficient mutual funds
and um so you'll be approaching 200 000
and I paid for 600 000 house if you
can't make it at least we know you could
sell the house and move to a 400 000
house well absolutely yeah we've
considered that uh I wouldn't do it
today but that's her that's her fall
back plan but if you could get the house
paid off and put 200 away I think you
could make it
well uh I'm we're fast tracking the
house we're paying an additional 1800 a
month against the principal and it it
looks to pay out in two and a half years
that's perfect
meanwhile meanwhile you got to do more
than that in addition into retirement
because I need to get a hundred and five
years that's 20 000 bucks that's another
1500 that's another 1800 a month
okay so I need to be putting another
1800 away into I just made that number
up Pastor I mean I just made it up it's
not it's not a trick number I just was
looking at a 70 000 income and I thought
how much can can we squeeze out of this
turnip
and I'm thinking there's no magic I mean
if I could have you have do have a
million when you're retired I'd do it
but I don't see that in the numbers I'm
trying to do something where you can eat
and still pull this off and get some
margin between you and the Wolf
okay okay and so that's where even
bullets yeah so if you saved 18 if you
saved 1800 that'd be twenty thousand you
did that for five years that'd be a
hundred thousand plus it will grow some
during that plus your 35 will grow some
during that so that'll bump you pretty
close to 200.
okay in your mutual funds and then you'd
have to pay for 600 000 house you're
almost a millionaire at that point
well I never thought about it like that
yeah awesome well that's a five that's
five or more years of working like
you're working now her too
okay perfect well I just need to get a
hold of one of your elps and help me
with the Roth thing I don't quite
understand all of that so jump on
smartvestor Smart investor
ramsesolutions.com and thank you for
your heart and uh your service and you
know we're just talking about that a
minute ago with parsonages and it's a
little different subject but uh gentle
big heart calling call a God on his life
without a doubt and he's staring down
the barrel of retirement he's got 30 000
bucks in the bank yep all right luckily
he's got a house he's got a great job do
something about it and good news is he
can do something about it still
um it's not going to be fancy but he can
do something about it so the house may
end up being the answer before it's over
but hopefully not hopefully we can work
it through without selling it if they
don't want to sell it but even held that
with an open hand you hear that yeah
spiritual maturity is amazing hey if you
enjoyed this episode which I gotta
assume you did because you're still
watching then go ahead and click on the
next episode all about money and
relationships things are about to get
spicy check it out